6 tips to overcome the challenges
of diversity in the workplace.
Managing a diverse team is not an easy task.
While it brings new ideas and perspectives
to your company,
it also poses certain challenges that can impact
productivity and performance.
To help you out,
here are 6 tips to
overcome the challenges of diversity in the workplace.
1, create an inclusive work environment.
A warm and supportive workplace
leads to hyperforming employees.
To achieve this,
ensure that everyone in your team feels
accepted and valued
regardless of their backgrounds,
beliefs and identities.
2, improve the hiring process.
Maintaining inequitable and unbiased hiring process
attracts a wider pool of candidates
from all walks of life.
This enables you to expand your workforce
and ultimately achieve your diversity goals.
3, establish company policies.
A set of well designed
policies helps deter incidents of discrimination,
harassment and bias in the workplace. So oh,
it's important to set clear guidelines for your company,
including the consequences for violating them.
For educate your employees.
Take the initiative to raise awareness
among your employees about the importance of diversity
in the workplace.
This way they will gain a clear understanding
of how it can help them as professionals and as a team.
5, promote effective teamwork.
Effective teamwork
plays a key role in building trust and collaboration.
Hence, it's important to ensure that your diverse
teams are working together toward a common goal
instead of competing against each other.
6, do social listening.
Gain valuable Insights into your employees workplace
experiences and concerns
by actively seeking their feedback and input.
This proactive approach will help you
identify and address any underlying issues
before they become larger problems.
On top of these tips,
it's also crucial to hire the right individuals
who can meet your business needs and expectations.
If you're struggling to build your team,
seek help from a reliable
outsourcing partner that understands your goals.
For more engaging content and workplace tips,
follow us on our social media accounts.